all right jay yep
jay where did you grow up where are you
from originally originally i'm from
south korea south korea yes and tell me
about your family
i was the only son
and my father was a
military for a long time in the army
and so
i grew up with all the guys
and even cook chef
everybody
no no no no females except my mom except
your mom yeah so that's mostly like you
know and i miss brothers i don't have a
brother real brother so
many uncles yes
how would you describe your childhood in
general
it was good it was good and then all of
a sudden uh
something changed
all of a sudden
me and between me and my father
all of a sudden he tried to go really uh
strictly
on me uh
when i become like a teenager
and then he sent me to us
by myself
first
age of 13 13 yeah by myself
did you speak english no only three
words
and at the time they didn't have esl
so i was having a hard time did you have
family to stay with here
no
his plan was
send the son in young age
and let him suffer let him learn and so
by the time
they get
you get here you'll be a man you're
right but it didn't work out that way
yeah things didn't work out that way
what happened
uh all of a sudden a few years later
when i was in
university
near here
and my mom got a stroke
all of a sudden and then uh your mom got
away stroll a stroke yeah and then
she got paralyzed half of her body
paralyzed she was inco she was in come
on for like six months really yeah so we
decided not to do surgery
just let it go
and
doctor said three months the longest but
she made it up
until 2014 so which is about 30
years 30 years more than 30 years wow
and you know
of course we have to you know
take you know take care of her really
good you know with a private doctor and
all that yeah
she made it that's great
yeah
finally she passed away
in 2014 yeah
that's where my
have it
have it
somehow i start
having that habit
from the uh that year somehow everything
just
yeah mentally
it's stressful to lose your mom
yeah and
it's kind of funny because well i don't
want to meet anybody
but i don't want to
be by myself
it's kind of funny huh yeah yeah i think
that's common so what i did was i went
to casino
like where crowded people but i don't
have to deal with them
i'm not alone casino you're gonna have
lots of people around you
rather than sitting by in the room by
myself and drink all day
so i chose to do that way
and
after that i started you know uh
because me i i when i look back i uh
learned um
i didn't know what the love was i
learned
sex first
truth is kind of funny
man everybody can see and listen but
i lost my virginity to my uh housemate
which was 10 12 years older
i was young i was only 12 years old
taking on that and then
so um
i didn't feel good about it at the time
that you know that when that happened
but uh
like a week after
i felt some kind of joy
even young age i feel so enjoying so i
learned
sex
since
when i was 12
and then
i didn't really seek for any other love
just physical love did you develop an
appetite for it after that first
experience
yeah and then i started looking for uh
she left
i mean my mom kicked her out she found
out
so
you know i have no nobody at the time
but uh you know i had that
urge
so
[Music]
i started going to uh uh
you know prostitute house
um
like a chicken wrench in here
little one they have those in korea yeah
like a black white block some like uh
you know here and there
and then
uh no miners can get in just it's just a
sign says
they allow you to come in
and young age
you know
before i came i i was not even 13 yet
stuck going there
and they treat me like a little boy
but you know
that's what it was and then when i came
to us
i forgot about all that
and just uh
deal with everyday problems language and
all that
and then uh
what kind of jobs have you had
jobs
i was many many there are many jobs i
went through but uh my own companies but
last one was um
uh
it's a
i call it production company
and we did uh we are real we subcontract
with the nokia and all that stiff center
uh
we uh uh pre-bend uh we provide all the
gears
stage lighting
sound whatever they need boost concert
whatever
and
video
so we are just a subcontractor by uh
yeah
by the contract and you've been married
before
yeah once i was still i didn't know what
the love was at the time
now i kind of know it's more of a
i guess commenting you know
i decide to do that it's like a
man to man you know like a mental woman
okay
so
i always wonder how can
when i saw somebody like couple we've
been together for six years
wow which is true
but how can you not get tired of one
person
i mean
so oh
there is true love
what is a true love
and then
something happened in 2014
somehow i got separated from my
my wife
and i had one son
and
he was 14 at the time
so they left
and i lost everybody my two
not blood blood brothers
real good brother for a long time
they got killed by accident
and then my mom passed away in san
francisco
so
i was really uh stressful and confused
and i need some time up so i just put
everything away
and took some time off
and
automatically nothing to do so
i was seeking
seeking woman
but it's the time to tell you the truth
not really for uh sex only
i wanna like have a company
but i pay for it it's easier that way
you know so
that's what i did then a friend of mine
i call him call him homie
he lives in compton
jay
let me take you to the enjoy your ride
then you told me to figure out figaro
street yeah manchester for you
well i never seen like i've been
together everywhere but this
streets blocked by black
everywhere
and there are like balls then they're
calling me mr lee
don't knock on your window yeah they
don't even know my name but just call me
i was laughing yeah and then uh
yeah it was kind of fun so i went
back there by myself
and you know keep doing that
and they have many motors there so
some of them has pimp some of them
freelancers
so i chose to be with the freelancers so
i can
pay a little more and study all night
and usually i don't talk i listen
i listen to their life story
i don't ask them how you become i cannot
but i just try to leave them too some of
the girls have very nice personalities
most of them are nice
and i feel so bad because
you know until i was investigating
situation
mentally
but oh when i heard them they were like
sexually abused by their own
some of their own parents
i can't believe that and uh
brother like
wow
when in their young age uncle
and they cannot
tell parents about that and then
wow
yeah they come from a very different
world yeah i was totally different and
then
they made me kind of cry
and the girls are beautiful yeah
beautiful and
very nice heart
and i guess the only thing is
somehow they got hooked
that's how i look at it me me too i
cannot walk somebody under somebody as
i've been walking by myself
it's kind of you know bothering
but
they know how to make money now
so they cannot go to a little liquor
store and work as a cashier because
you know
it doesn't make sense to them they're
used to making 700 a night right so even
though they share with them you know
whoever they still make few hundred a
day
rather than
standing up and work hard
make hundred dollars
so i understand
i feel them
so
they became my friends you know so
i and you
it sounds like mostly good experiences
doing this yeah especially uh
i never really expected
figuring manchester united
that was kind of really funny
yeah it's kind of fun do you ever have
bad experiences
uh not really
not really because of what
not really
and i
yeah over there people say yeah south
central and over there it's bad and
dangerous area for me
everywhere ugly good and bad you know so
actually more is safer over there i
guess if you know
people
yeah
so but those women
young young two
some of them are 19 20
and
when they talk they cry
for that man
and you have sex as well yeah but not
all the time
i think it's in here when i get mentally
satisfied i don't feel the need to have
a sex
and i think this you know will benefit
them you know because they get money
anyhow they don't have to work
right yeah that's a nice it's a nice
yeah they'll spend an hour if they're
just kidding yeah and they get paid
without doing anything just talk right
and lay down right but uh some of them
you know
forced me to have a service
so well
i don't know i got mixed up but you know
i don't understand that part yeah have
you ever developed feelings for any of
these women
uh not only for them i don't really
develop feelings
you know towards women yeah uh only my
wife because i tried to well
it was hard because of all
uh she's a nice woman
but she doesn't know anything
i have to take care everything from
beginning to the end
very tiring when i come back home still
i gotta go to dmv
okay and
so
there's there's all kinds of different
women on figaro street there's the black
women there's mexicans
yeah
do you have any preference
i don't really have but
different uh character mainly
i like black people
i like hispanic too but very different
[Music]
style
and most of them are good but
black people has more souls
somehow in their soul
i i didn't know that but yeah they are
all under
everybody all the black people have have
that i guess
and
they try to uh
you know be together
and they are not against other color but
you know i think when a
when a person
and a black woman
who's been through
when a person's had a very rough right
right existence right yeah and being an
african-american female
first off she's female then she's
african-american she's probably poor
right she's had very few opportunities
she's had a very rough yeah it makes it
makes them
incredibly strong and soulful wow i
can't believe that yeah and she this
they've overcome adversities that most
of us have never seen
she makes good money not only she's
doing that at the same time she has done
a double job doubling everything she
said doubling mine what is that double
pleasure
at the same time most of the clients
want dope
she sell
at the same time she got all kinds you
know
so uh
so i talked to her one night and then
she started talking and then she said
she came from louisiana
by herself in her young age
went to came to l.a
as soon as she got to l.a she got raped
start from there
oh agony i heard
wow
and they met just like that they made
her struggle but made her stronger
stronger swimmer now no she can do
whatever she wants
but uh it wasn't
easy
she she's a tough woman but she made it
and
yeah
yeah a lot of these women have great
personalities yeah very nice
you're like
wow look at all these women and they're
cool looking too
beautiful yeah very beautiful woman and
you know good thing about them there is
a
we like like they serve me serve like a
some snacks copper noodle
i'll try to cook no no no let me like
that i really love that guy you know
like
being a good friend what i find unusual
about that whole marketplace is there'll
be women out there that are the most
beautiful and women you could ever find
in the um
yeah
and you'll find
ones that are not as desi no
the very bottom of the barrel right but
they're all the same price yeah they're
all the same price they're all basically
a hundred dollars for whatever you want
right i mean some of them hustle you for
a little more and some of them can't but
for a hundred dollars you can get
and you're right but anything in the
grocery store me i never uh you know i
never said about the price right there i
always give more so you think that some
of the beautiful
attractive ones would be five hundred
dollars and the the undesirable ones
would be 60 or
right
but they're all they're all 100.
yeah
to me there could be an actress too yeah
if they meet the right people
so beautiful naturally the lack of role
models lack of opportunity kind of gives
them
unlimited yeah hispanic
ladies too young and beautiful yeah yeah
so beautiful
are drugs a part of your life
drugs me yes
i used to smoke uh
with when i was young because i i play
music
and after that when i came to us
i started taking
cocaine
and then 1992
i was smoking crack
and i quit one day
and then when i
went to uh
figueroa in 2014 and all that from there
little by little
some crack so it depends on how what
they smoke
so if they want some i buy for them and
we smoke together
yeah
like casually yeah so
but uh
for fun but uh
some of them are really hooked
i can tell
really hooked so it's like
they are depending on that yeah
maybe
yeah i don't know
[Music]
are there any particular stories
that you've had on some of the girls
with some of the girls on figaro street
that
were interesting
uh
actually uh can i talk about that to you
yeah
i thought she
i thought she was beautiful and
everything okay she didn't tell me
anything but when he got into room
and she was not a woman
oh really
oh
are you you usually uh see them on santa
monica melrose in l.a right nice looking
but telling their surgery if they had i
couldn't tell right
by looking right
oh
and sorry i didn't have the money
oh you know what uh i'm not
oh there was a kind of a
stunning moment for me you know
why
that
that guy
tried to get me without asking you know
all that
for the money so i gave him some money
yeah and please get out
yeah there was yeah
man oh one more one more thing
there is uh this is a technique they do
they try to rip you up
uh
then you go to the motel room
and then later
the guy in the condor
and then that's my girl and blah blah
blah after she got pays first you know
they do that
travelers
so they do it to get your money get your
wallet yeah like a strangers
uh they don't know them and travelers
and
they push in the room
don't get a room i have a room female
when she female says that be careful
you gotta get a room not her
and she takes you to a motor room she
was in nobody there you go in
you pay her about to do something be
negative take a shower when you come out
guy somebody know who is it and then guy
comes in with a gun
if you had this happen
they tried to do that to me but they
couldn't do it yeah
yeah somehow yeah but
that's
yeah they do it how they do it so be
careful when the ladies try to take you
i i hope this helps
what's your favorite thing about these
girls that do this kind of work
um
first of all uh they don't look sad
that's why what i like about and they
don't really uh okay
uh there are other kind of uh
women they do the same thing
but uh you don't call them prostitutes
you don't you call them addicts drug
addicts
and they are not really prostitutes but
they do the same thing they uh
prostitutes to have sex with uh
whoever they give them to give them dope
you know same thing right more money
so uh they are really uh dark side when
you look at them they are like
tired and this girl so bright like this
whole world is mine hey
happy happy so i like it you know over
there the ones without the drug
addiction
yeah i don't know drug addiction uh
people
they are so depressed
they don't look right
but these
ladies on uh figueroa
they are so happy they look so heavy i
don't know why inside they look look so
happy maybe hiding it but
every day singing
waving
mr lee
what is your biggest regret in your life
uh in my life yes
regret
yeah i might be victory over my
mom yeah before she got paralyzed she
made about 30 more years but
you know there's no greater love than
mom
except godzilla but
you know i want to tell everybody
my regret i i could have done a lot
better
to my mom
you know
yeah
i did all that after but she was
paralyzed yeah
she couldn't even
say my name
so
yeah
and jay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh
first lesson that is uh
i i i'm personally telling you from my
you know personal thought i cannot leave
this world by myself
i could
go you
many us in u.s many people just go to
work busy come back
and
sleep tired you
you know same thing it's like a hamster
rolling
you know every day and then they get kid
they have to raise their responsibility
and then
where's their life
but um you know sometimes you have to
look up the sky and look around and you
know
that doesn't mean i'm there but i'm
going there and
what is more important to you right now
look around you have to really look
around i guess
and
see what's more important to you there
are people think about them again you
know they are so precious to you you
might
lose them you know you lose them in the
future before you lose them
do your best it's not like a give and
take
money talks possible no no just just
give
just share
and don't expect anything in return and
you can't have that joy that nobody
knows
in your heart
that's what i want to do you know
for the rest of my life and
i started doing that little by little
it's beautiful yeah all right jay thank
you so much for sharing your story oh
thank you thank you thank you so much
have fun this weekend all right thank
you
thank you
you